so this is such a personal experience
obviously
um how did you first meet Augusto and
Paulina and what made you want to turn
their story into a film
yeah I'm well I know them from all my
life because they are very well known
people in Chile but I approached to them
after I was hired to make a lecture in a
university and Paulina worked there in
that University and I saw her in a work
context with him and I realized that she
bring him to work and I saw that all the
community that work with her
were like taking care of him with her
and it was the first time that I saw a
person with dementia or a person that
was dependent like integrated into
society and not isolated and I saw them
really in love
and a few months before I read a big
interview that I was to make in a big
magazine telling openly that he has
Alzheimer's so it was like a bravely
loveling and unexpected situation for me
that really blow my mind and and I start
trying to convince them to make a film
Paulina said no from the first day and
for many months it was a very radical no
and
and I tell to her like I want to make a
love story she was like there is not
love story here and I also was very
clear from the beginning and he helped
me to combine her
so Paulina then was it Augusto that
convinced you was it my there what was
it that finally made you decide
um
she wasn't convinced until she saw the
movie with everyone with an audience
like you just watched it
[Music]
when she saw it she it was then that she
understood why Augusto uh never never
said no and was always willing and and
wanting to do it
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
public that he had Alzheimer's in a very
public
interviews
and then became like an icon or like a
figure of visibility for the disease in
in the country
and he he was first diagnosed in 2014.
um so for both of you
um you document them together in very
over the course of four years or more
um and it's a very intimate portrait
there's moments that are very personal
um were there was there anything that
was off limits in terms of covering it
yeah it's a good question about the
limits because
as documentary filmmakers we always ask
ourselves about the limits and there are
a lot of theory about the limits but at
the end the limits you're only living
leave it when you are on the film and
each film had its own limits as and in
any relationship in life you construct
your limits together so as you said it
was a five-year process of shooting and
at the beginning we start to construct
or build our relationship in a very slow
a way and
and we we were trying to understand
where when and but the biggest question
about the limit was about the end
because I always said I wanted to be
with them until the end but the end was
very abstract and it was further son and
daughter and for Paulina well but until
which degree and and when the End come
of the film not his
and because he passed away one year and
more after that we finished the film so
we finished the shooting so the end for
me was very clear the day that they were
walking and he said I'm not anymore
Paulina said you are not I'm not and it
was the first time that he was saying
like I don't feel comfortable with
myself and it was the first time that I
felt after five years uncomfortable with
the camera there and that was clearly
the end and that it's the limits like
when when you feel that you're in an
uncomfortable situation I think
a limit
point of severeign
so you probably would have noticed that
there was a part of the movie that she
had to record herself during covid
ES dosanos
the covert restrictions in Chile were
particularly strict so it took over two
years for for them to be loosened
um is
so a lot of the footage you just watched
has a high degree of intimacy and
exposure
because they never thought that that
would actually have to be part of the
movie
apart
besides being very badly filmed by her
Duro
but it was a way to stay together her
and Maita through through a very very
hard hard period of time
and and the in one way to keep going
with her research and and project
[Music]
so they really never had any limits
yeah it was through through my test uh
love and respect and above everything
the the dignity that she treated
everything that was assembled in the
assembly process that that yeah that the
material was found
speaking of the assembly processes I
understand it it was the cruise small it
was you the Director of Photography of
the sound engineer
but for this is more for Paulina I guess
I mean it seems like you managed
something really amazing which is to S
to really be invisible
did were you conscious or aware you know
how aware were you of the crew when they
were there
foreign
levels of
of comfort and proximity and the
relationship that there were with the
cameras between Augusta and the cameras
all throughout his life Augusta was very
used to being in front of a camera
he was never bothered he was always
comfortable with a camera being around
him
so she also appealed to to her own
nature
um
she's an actress
and in order to be able to work as an
actress you have to forget that there
are cameras there
and she and that's something very
evident in the final product
and only one thing and it was funny for
us because in my dop that I work with
him in all my films was the
dop of auston his programs so he really
moved with him with the camera like he
never put the back to the camera like he
was always very conscious of Pablo and
and his presence all the time yeah
yeah but it's also I think that they
were both very conscious like I always
try to be invisible and wear a very
small crew and we try to stay quiet but
yeah they know that we are there yeah
and you chose to make this a non-linear
film you didn't tell this
chronologically
um and it seems like the moments are
edited together maybe by images and
associations what was the thinking
behind that as opposed to making it
linear
yeah I think that it's a film that was
born really in the editing room because
in that place I understand and I wrote
the film because
um
it's a film that it's suited for for the
three of us for three generations
Paulina me and I was still in different
periods of life and when I put all that
together I understood that I was not
constructed a story with a classical
narrative because it's a chronic of a
deterioration and everybody knows the
end of that
so the The Narrative was the
associations that you do you need to
make to understand the present so how
the past is related and how we were
building a feeling and uh an eternal
memory like I I start with idea to only
shoot this love story but in the road I
realized that that I was there was
someone that always remembers certain
things that there is a body that's
always remember the feelings and and he
remember
his friend that passed away he
remembered dictatorship
he remember the the love he remembered
their pains so
um I have to make the relationships with
the things that he was still remembering
and he works for memory and he give me
the signs of that too like the the
writing that he put to her in the book
it was like he was telling me that I
have to take care about the historical
memory because he was on that
he worked for that so that's how we make
the relationships that was born in the
editing room
seemed like such a sad irony in a way
that you know he was this prominent
cultural commentator and he dealt so
much with memory uh it feels like your
film acquires more layers of meaning
because of that you know because of your
country's painful memories and then the
fact that he is losing some of the
memory
yeah but but I don't think it
yeah it's pain but yeah but but
it's not really pain for me it's it's
like so uh there is something important
in I think that dictatorship and
um
an Alzheimer's uh puts you in a
fertility situation when you understand
that you cannot control history and you
cannot control life and and I think that
he was so consequenced in that uh
preservation of the memory that it's
always there it's an an eternal memory
anyway so in that way I I didn't feel it
ironic or or sad I I felt that that is
there until the end yeah
a
um
and
as someone who worked I also worked with
with memory and about memory uh his
entire life and with film the fact that
um it all kind of culminates in a
project about memory and and in a film
of what memory is perhaps the most
coherent
the most coherent uh thing that could
have uh happened and
and that in in that it's making everyone
watching make an exercise in memory by
watching the story unfold
so not that ironic
so much strength in patience Paulina
um I wondered how you kept that strength
and maybe if you could talk about what
was most difficult for you and also what
were your happiest moments during the
course of this filming
a
[Music]
um
this movie is also very truthful and in
displaying all the hardships of the
disease
it's not hiding anything
but at the same time it's showing the
other side of the disease the Nemos
much
there's a lot of time to learn how to
say goodbye to someone else came
OS
and to learn how everyone needs to have
someone else to rely on encounter
solos
no we don't we aren't born by ourselves
and there's no reason why we should die
by ourselves
and this disease she always says is
death in slow motion
um
Tiempo but
is a separation and so it gives you time
to to Grapple and understand the the
separation that's about to happen
and what needs to be done when when the
moment finally arrives
the other thing is like yes this is hard
and because of that you also have to
kind of give it to the other side and
balance it out
because you can't avoid the pain
but you can't avoid suffering
this
might they what was the most challenging
aspect for you making this film
I I I enjoy to make this film a lot it
was
the kind of couples that you really want
to be with like when people is happy
together like it was very unbelievable
because if you read in the paper it's
like yeah they are
passing for a bad time but when I was
there like I was always very happy to be
there so I will say I really enjoyed the
shooting all the time I really wanted to
be with them
and I think the most challenging was of
course the pandemic and to
we thought that we were going to finish
the film the film is was not going to
continue
so we yeah that to send the camera was
away as Paulina said to have a diary
between us and to understand what was
happening there until I will be back
um and yeah and it was like that
abstraction at the end it was a gift
uh because the level of intimacy
and the level of that profound
situations even if I have all the access
I will never
have that material anyway because only a
couple that it's a long
can have that that material so I think
that that was the most challenging thing
like to
uh understand what to do during the
lockdown
must have had lots of hours of footage
because you shot it and then you had the
archival footage and then what was shot
during the covid how many hours did you
amass I think that it's not so much it
was like 60 something like that
no I'm usually two 300 it's like 60 it's
you can you can manage that yeah yeah
um so your last film The Mole agent was
also dealt with aging to some degree
um what is it about this subject that
interests you
um I think that it's related but it's
completely the opposite in the in
demolition
in demolition it was a group of people
that was completely isolated from
society because they were dependent and
when I see this I came from that and it
was like
uh yeah it's different and and I think
that
yeah what's moved me it's to see what we
usually put out of society and put the
eye
in how to see their fertility and how to
deal with
um
yeah with um
B aging and be dependent I think
Paulina I wanted to ask you was there
anything new that you learned about
Augusto during the process of making
this film or when you saw the finished
film
yes
that's a new question for her
foreign
[Music]
and
um yes so uh I'll go show us as many men
of his age uh thought he had a a strong
uh grasp of his own identity
reflection
yes
on his own ability to think to to
understand the world his logic his uh
yeah his
um
foreign
and when the disease started his more
emotional depth started to show up
and you all probably saw that and enjoy
it
um
the
their nuda he was a man full of
tenderness
very loving
[Music]
so she discovered the the best parts of
him through this disease
and uh we're gonna need to wrap up I
just have one last question for you
Maite
um what did you learn about Alzheimer's
or or just the was there something that
really struck you
yeah
I think that each case is different and
each case if particular and I cannot
make a statement about Alzheimer for one
person but
I think that I learned that there are
things that that's the what I say before
that's the body remember like the body
remember the love I
I saw him like until the end remembering
the smell the
he recognized her and he recognized so
many things always so I really
feel that when you have love the the
body is going to remember
I love that that's a beautiful note to
finish up on here thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]